Speaker 1: yesterday or late the day before. A 12
page letter was released to the media, supposedly
written by Donald Trump, weighing in on the Trump
riot committee hearings. Now, I don't believe
for a second that Donald Trump really wrote a
12 page letter. Trump doesn't write and Trump
doesn't read all he's capable of. As far as we've
seen is a tweet style messages, often with strange
grammar, spelling and syntax. So I don't believe
Trump wrote a 12 page letter. But I do believe
that Trump sat somewhere and told someone what
to write. And Chris Cillizza from CNN received
the letter and gave us a list of the wackiest
things. And here are some some key, key moments
from this statement that shows us how the right
is thinking of these hearings. Number one, if they
had any real evidence, they'd hold real hearings
with equal representation. Remember, Republicans
opted out of that. There was a framework for an
actual bipartisan committee ten members, five
Republicans, five Democrats, Democratic chair,
Republican vice chair, and both the chair and vice
chair have to agree on every subpoena. Republicans
rejected it. So Democrats did what they could,
which is they've got Liz Cheney and Adam Kinzinger
on the panel so that that's their fault. Two, they
use the illegally constituted committee to put on
a smoke and mirrors show for the American people
in a pitiful last ditch effort to deceive the
American public again. There's nothing illegal
about the committee. Just nothing. We've had other
committees, the Benghazi one. We've had others
perfectly legal. Number three, they've refused to
allow their political opponents to participate in
the process. They've excluded exculpatory
witnesses and anyone who so easily points
out the flaws in their story. Again, as Chris
Cillizza writes, Republicans crushed the actual
bipartisan committee that they wanted to do,
that it is because of Republicans that they
don't have more Republicans on the committee.
And also a whole bunch of the pro-Trump people
that were subpoenaed didn't go. And that's now the
subject of legislation that includes Steve Bannon
and Peter Navarro. Navarro for the unselected
pseudo committee, has coordinated with their media
puppets to broadcast their witnesses on TV without
opposition cross-examination or rebuttal evidence.
Again, more than a thousand depositions were taken
of all sorts of witnesses. It is untrue that that
is what was done. And then a whole bunch of other
just repetition of lies. I won't look at all of
these, but number seven is they illegally
inflated voter rolls. That's unproven. They
illegally allowed harvested and stuffed ballots.
No evidence of that. They abused the use of mail
in ballots. That's there's no evidence of that.
They physically removed Republicans from counting
facilities. That's untrue. Now, there are random
Republicans who showed up demanding to oversee the
election who were not allowed to because there's
a process for establishing observers there. There
were Republican and Democratic observers. There
were people who just showed up demanding access.
It's sort of like if I go, you know, if I go to a
court and I say I want to sit alongside the judge,
they would say, well, no, you haven't been
selected. You're not the judge. In the same way.
If I'm not actually an election observer, I don't
have a right to just show up and be given power
there. But there is no evidence for any of those
claims and a whole bunch of other stuff that
doesn't really have any meaning. Like Donald
Trump writing in this letter on election night,
America watched as my lead grew and grew over
Biden as I was set to claim another victory.
We expected the red mirage. We expected that
the early vote would favor Trump and that as
the cities were counted overnight and into the
next day, it would start to point more in the
direction of Joe Biden. All of these things we
expected. So I don't believe Trump wrote this,
but I do believe he had input. And it really shows
us that they aren't changing their talking points.
Every day that passes, we have more of an
empirical basis to reject their claims,
but they continue making the exact same
claims day after day after day. Now,
at the end of the day, I don't know that these
hearings are really going to have any impact.
They're getting an okay audience. My guess is the
people watching are mostly the people who already
don't believe the things that Donald Trump has
been saying. So whether these hearings will have
any impact whatsoever remains to be seen. But the
the lies that they are telling continue to be the
exact same lies. And at this point, I don't know
who's falling for them. We'll have more on this on
our Instagram, which you can find at David Pakman
show. We'll be back right after this short break.